pandas man who doesn't love pandas
they're already legendary for their
sneezes
and their reactions to sneezes but they
also love slides
playing in leaves and eating 10 to 14
hours
every day i mean i'm not necessarily one
for spirit animals but uh
that panda lifestyle sounds awfully
relatable to me but you know who doesn't
love pandas
a surprising number of naturalists and
economists who write articles with
not-so-cuddly titles like
why i hate pandas and you should too and
humans should stop meddling with pandas
and let them die
and pandas aren't cute they're
death-loving oxygen
thieves yikes i mean sure we do spend a
lot of conservation money on animals
that seem uninterested in mating for the
survival of their own species but ask
yourself this
if we let pandas die who is going to
become the dragon warrior to save all of
china yeah now you see how important
pandas are
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that studies martial arts
footage in super slow motion to make
sure that everyone is in fact
kung fu fighting rather than like you
know judo fighting or
kepura fighting or krav maga fighting
dear viewer if you've been on the
cinematic journey that i call film
theory for more than a few episodes you
already know my would be creepy if it
weren't my job level obsession with kids
movies
but now it's even less creepy because
i've got myself a toddler and i can
spend quality time with my son watching
something that we can both enjoy
well bonus still getting my work done on
the side
multitasking for the win our most recent
father-son feature
kung fu panda my son loved the movie but
as any of you who've ever been around a
toddler know
little kids are prototheorists who ask a
lot of questions
luckily his questions so far have been
pretty simple what's that a panda what's
he doing
kung fu boom nailing it but as it gets
older those questions are going to start
to get more sophisticated how is the
panda such a good fighter why did oogway
choose poe to be the dragon warrior to
save the valley in the first place as
opposed to literally anyone else
why do all the animals have themselves
creepy human teeth
hmm reasonable questions all future
version of my son
and while i can't answer the third one
today i do want to cover the first two
why is poe of all the animals the dragon
warrior what makes
poe so special you ever notice that it
never really gets that solid of an
explanation in the movie in a fictional
world where there's already plenty of
other highly skilled and trained
warriors what makes this random panda
the chosen one
oh there's a reason and that reason is
getting this thing in the chinese
theater so i can make boatloads of cash
and what's become the most important
theatrical market in the world
but the cynical realities of filmmaking
aside i
do believe that there is also a reason
in universe for why poe is the perfect
candidate above and beyond everyone else
and it's not what you'd expect so shove
as many dumplings in your mouth as you
can and rest those comment fingers of
fury we're
jump kicking into the world of kung fu
panda
skadoosh when master oogway determines
that poe is in fact a dragon warrior a
mythical hero he foretold would one day
save the valley and gain limitless power
most of the other characters were
skeptical that poe could possibly be a
great warrior for one main reason
his body type they're not exactly subtle
about it either look at you
this fat flavions
i'm in this ridiculous belly now this
kind of stuff was probably my least
favorite part of kung fu panda because
it's perpetuating some negative
stereotypes about bodies that just flat
out aren't true
the idea that you have to have yourself
six-pack abs in order to be a good
athlete or
a good fighter isn't just biased it's
actually scientifically inaccurate and
no i'm not just talking about sumo
wrestlers here for instance in 2019 the
heavyweight boxing champion of the world
was this guy anthony joshua and he faced
off against this guy
andy ruiz jr anthony joshua looks like
what we've been conditioned to think
that an elite athlete should look like
and andy ruiz
doesn't but since i'm bringing this up
you probably know how this story is
gonna end
ruiz knocked joshua down four times
throughout the fight ultimately winning
by tko that's some technical knockout
for those of you who've never played
punch out before
sure they had themselves a rematch that
anthony joshua won by decision but andy
ruiz has
33 wins in the ring and only two defeats
as a professional boxer so it's not like
he's some nobody who just threw one
lucky punch sports nutritionist dr mayor
ranchurtis said after the fight that
ruiz's additional mass was actually
working to his advantage and that's
simple physics since force
is mass times acceleration more mass
behind the punch means a stronger punch
ruiz is also not the only elite fighter
with this sort of body type this is
daniel cormier one of only a handful of
mixed martial artists ever to hold the
championship
in multiple different weight classes
serena williams has faced
all sorts of criticisms about her body
mainly that she's too muscular to play
tennis which let's be real you're too
muscular to be an
athlete is probably one of the dumbest
of dumb takes but no figure she's almost
undoubtedly the greatest woman's tennis
player in history
we could do this all day the point is
that looking at someone's body shape
tells you
nothing about their physical skill their
flexibility strength speed balance or
any other attribute that actually
matters in athletic performance
can poe be the dragon warrior despite
not having washboard abs and giant
biceps of course he can
and in terms of how much strength he can
put behind his strikes his weight
may actually be acting as an advantage
there's also an argument to be made that
poe's body type makes him a better
warrior not just because he can inflict
more damage but also because he can
absorb more damage apparently pandas
fall out of trees all the time and
according to zookeepers don't usually
get injured as much as they get
embarrassed
just when i thought pandas couldn't get
any more relatable anyway science
suggests that their added body fat might
be helping them avoid
injury when this happens a 2003 study
found that higher levels of subcutaneous
fat quote was associated with
significantly decreased
injury for people in car accidents a
study from leeds beckett university
also demonstrated that overweight
individuals had a higher pressure pain
tolerance than those whose body mass
indexes were in the normal range and
this
isn't just me randomly applying real
world science to a fictional movie we
see it
actively play out in the films in kung
fu panda 2 ho takes a blast from lord
shen's canon at nearly point-blank range
and he manages to survive it because it
hits him in his more cushioned
midsection
and in the original kung fu panda the
snow leopard tai lung's special attack
looks like it affects his opponent's
nerves as he uses it to paralyze the
furious 5.
but poe is immune to that attack in his
final battle and instead of being
paralyzed by it he just gets tickled
given
mantis's difficulty finding pose
pressure points earlier in the movie due
to his returned physique it appears that
carrying a few more lbs's is
poe's secret offensive and defensive
weapon
but matpat aren't pandas super low
energy and lazy wouldn't that make poe a
terrible fighter
yes the letter to the editor that we
seem to get every episode it's true that
normal pandas have low metabolic rates
and are seen as relatively slow moving
and lazy but
poe isn't a normal panda see the main
reason that pandas have such slow
metabolisms is that their diets are
horribly inefficient pandas have short
digestive tracts which is perfect for
eating meat but instead they spend
10 plus hours per day eating bamboo to
get their nutritional needs and then
because they can't digest it all that
well they have to poop about
40 times a day you heard that right 40
batches of panda pellets per day
shaman really should have been using
pandas on all those ad campaigns but on
a more chemical level it means that
pandas have extremely low
levels of the hormone tyrosine which
regulates thyroid function and things
like energy usage
but you'll notice that poe's diet isn't
bamboo
it's well everything else especially
dumplings and bean buns and tofu
all the things that mr ping serves and
wouldn't you know it
meat soybeans and other legumes are all
the foods that are highest in tyrosine
so it's likely that po
is eating a diet that both will make him
much more energetic than the normal
panda while
also saving him time on chewing wood and
clogging a septic tank maybe
that diet is just what we needed to turn
an ordinary panda into a martial arts
master
so that's all well and good poe's body
type is actually helping him attack with
more force and
cushion blows more easily his special
diet is making him more energetic than
your average panda but still
why didn't oogway just choose one of the
furious five as a dragon warrior i mean
this one has always bugged me since you
know they were all seasoned kung fu
experts to begin with and poe was
not so i did some digging and realized
that while yes they all knew kung fu
they didn't know the right kind of kung
fu
see calling kung fu only one thing is
like saying basketball and water polo
are the same sport because in both
you're trying to throw a ball into a net
there are a ton of different styles of
kung fu including the shaolin animal
styles
what are five of the most common animal
styles provided you're not including in
and out secret menu
i bet you can guess tiger monkey crane
snake
and mantis just like we see in the movie
but you were wondering why there was a
random mantis as part of the team huh
well now you know it's a dedicated style
of kung fu
each of these styles is used by its
corresponding member of the furious five
but none of them in particular use
another common animal style
the dragon style now there's no such
thing as panda style in the real world
but poe
actually has some instincts that would
help him utilize that dragon style most
effectively one of the defining elements
of dragon style kung fu
is the dragon step which moves in this
unconventional zigzag kind of dance and
before po
receives any training his instinct is to
use as he calls him his crazy feet and
given that the dragon style is in many
ways a mashup of techniques from
all the other animal styles poe is in a
great position to learn it because we
know he's been a super fan of the
furious five since the beginning he's
been studying slash
practicing their techniques in his
bedroom since day one it's one of the
first things that we know about him each
member of the furious five can have
their own specialization but by learning
from
all of them poe is laying the groundwork
to become the dragon warrior master
without ever realizing it in fact oogway
kind of tells us this at the end of kung
fu panda 3 that his vision for the
dragon warrior was someone who could
serve as a sort of connecting point
on the first day we met i saw the
future of kung fu and the past i
saw the panda who could unite them both
that is why i chose you po
both sides of the yin and yang oogway
ari knew from his own experience that
pandas had the ability to master chi
the spiritual elements of kung fu but
his mention of yin and yang here
is relevant even though oogway's first
impression of poe is that he's a buffoon
who just crash landed in front of him he
sees the opposing side that is pose
potential that's why when oogway laid
eyes on what appeared to be a clumsy
unassuming panda he knew that inside was
also a graceful
and powerful dragon unless when oogway
says that he saw both sides of the yin
and yang he means
po was black and white and his fur made
him literally look like a yin yang sign
not the whole body shape thing and
mastering different styles and
nah that's definitely not that thing it
was clearly the body shape and the diet
and his super phantom of the furious
five that made him the perfect dragon
warrior oh and uh also the whole make
money in china thing that one's that
one's actually probably the most
important
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and fun fact you know i was able
to watch
kung fu panda in order to make this
theory with the help of our sponsor for
today's episode nordvpn
that is not a joke this is a true story
so for years i've been telling you guys
about how nord protects your privacy
online with its military military-grade
encryption
in fact your information is double
encrypted for increased anonymity and it
works across all your different devices
which is super important for something
like your phone when you're using
unsecured networks but
here's a real-world example of how i
used nord
for this very episode kung fu panda
isn't streaming here in the us
or i guess it is but it's streaming on
hbo max and i've been really reticent to
get hbo max because i refused to get yet
another subscription service so i used
nord to switch to a different server
literally one click and suddenly it
looks like i live in japan
where lo and behold kung fu panda 1 and
3 are streaming on netflix but what
about kung fu panda 2 well click again
and i'm suddenly in the uk where kung fu
panda 2
is available alongside a bunch of other
dreamworks classics like megamind heck i
was even able to find myself a new kung
fu panda series i wasn't familiar with
secrets of the scroll
without nord i would have had to pay for
all of those movies which would have
cost me anywhere between like
16 bucks on the low low end to at least
and let me be clear in that single
moment nord paid for itself for the
entire
year and that was just one weekend for
just these movies i can do that to find
pretty much
any movie that i want here in the states
you're paying for like at least
three subscription services to see
everything you want with the power of
nord
a global netflix has basically got
everything you could possibly want so
stay protected
across all your different devices while
also staying entertained
and saving you money in the process all
thanks to nord go to nordvpn.com
film theory and use the code film theory
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o
to get yourself 68 off a two-year plan
plus an additional month for free that
is nordvpn.com
film theory with the code film theory at
checkout link is down below
first line of the description skadoosh